we are less than two weeks away now from
remembrance events taking place in the
valley to honor all of the victims of
one october
this marks three years now since that
tragic night
hector mejia live from the healing
garden downtown with more on the
preparations good morning hector
hey there alex good morning there's been
a lot of outpour of love from the
community here to uh
beautify the healing garden so many
different groups so many hours spent
here let's show you what it looks like
right now so we have
a lot of work here that's been done by
so many volunteers in our community and
as you were just mentioning
there is sadly one more name to add to
the memorial here and that is samantha
arjun here at channel 8 we had the
chance to
profile her journey as she tried to
recover she was telling us she was in a
lot of pain
trying to recover from a gunshot wound
to her leg
i had a chance to speak to her father
yesterday he talked to us about the pain
that samantha arjun was
unable to recover and sadly she passed
away
in late may her father understandably
shocked and also devastated and about
next month on one october on the
three-year mark at night i believe it's
around 10 pm
when it happens every year ever since
that night that they read the names of
all of the victims we are expecting to
see that again this year and out here we
have volunteers here
getting the grounds ready beautifying
freshening things up and we've seen some
changes out here we have a gate a fence
around the healing garden here
and this will be the site one of many
sites uh
on one october on the three-year mark to
honor all of the victims and for
a lot of us who have been here in las
vegas for either a few years or who grew
up here
we know someone who was there that
tragic night either a co-worker
a family member or people who we have
profiled before
and it's really a touching touching
moment to be here just
two weeks away from the three year mark
all right that's our update from out
here
reporting live hector mejia 8 news now
back to you guys
yeah it's so hard to believe hector
thank you for that the garden looks very
nice
the vegas strong 5k is still happening
this year but it will be virtual because
of the pandemic
so it's coming up here sunday september
27th you can run virtually on just runs
facebook page
registration is 50 all proceeds go to
organizations like the resiliency center
they also help with upkeep at the
healing garden you can find a list of
events happening to commemorate the
three years since 1 october
it's all on our website 8newsnow.com